Hey look guys my name is the Cherno and
welcome back to my stay plus plus series
a lot of time we talked about
constructors in C++ and what they are
and how to use them definitely check out
that video if you haven't already and
today we're going to talk about that
evil twin B destructor so it's the only
how a constructor runs when you create a
new instance of an object a destructor
runs when you destroy an object so any
time an object gets destroyed the
destruction method will get called the
constructor is usually we set variables
up or do any kind of initialization that
you need to do and similarly the
destructor is where you uninitialized
anything that you might have to or clean
any memory that you've used the
destructor applies to both stack and
heap allocated objects so if you
allocate an object using new when you
call delete the destructor will get
called if you just have a stack-based
object and when the scope and the object
will get deleted and thus the destructor
will get called let's dive in and take a
look at some examples so in the
constructor video we created this
wonderful entity class which had
multiple constructors here let's go
ahead and add a destructor and these
structure begins with a tilde and then
the name of our class so basically the
only difference between an constructor
and destructor in terms of declaration
and definition is the actual tilde that
you put out the front of the destructor
now you know at the destructor in this
case we just have a single class with
two members x and y there is absolutely
no cleaner when you do some memories
here at all since these two floats are
allocated in place where our class will
talk more about memory allocations and
all of our complicated stuff in the
future so don't you worry but for
example let's go ahead and add a message
which tells us that the object has been
deleted so I might write something like
destroyed empty and that's a fine in our
constructor here I'm going to write
constructor and T or I guess we should
call it created since the cult is
destroyed and not disrupted I want to
get rid of is constructed it's okay to
confused I'll initialize X and Y is 0 as
well just so we're not crazy I'll get
rid of this as well
now since this is duck allocated we will
only see the destructor getting called
when the main function exits which we're
not really going to see because our
program will close immediately after
that so I'm going to just write a
function here which will perform all of
our entity operations I'll move all this
code over here and I will call function
now if I run my code just like this you
should be created entity then our print
function running which prints x and y
and then finally destroyed entity let's
take a deeper look at the how this works
I'm going to put a breakpoint on line 28
here next to our entity and here f5
currently about absolutely nothing in a
console if I hit f10 here and look back
you can say that my entity has been
created I'm now going to hit f10 to
print and you can see that my x and y
position gets printed and finally the
end of the scope is reached here we're
about a jump back to line 34 which is
our return address since this object was
created on the stack it should get
automatically destroyed when it goes out
of scope which is right over here so if
I hit f10 you can see that destroyed
entity gets printed to the console
because the destructor is called we jump
back to our return address and
everything is good so that is
essentially what a destructor is it's
just a special function and special
method which gets called when an object
gets destroyed after some real-world
examples as to why you would ever write
a destructor well again if there is
certain initialization code that you
call it in the constructor you would
likely want to uninitialized or destroy
all that starts in the destructor
because if you don't you can get memory
leaks a good example of that is heap
allocated objects if you've allocated
any kind of memory on the heap manually
and you need to manually clean it up if
it was allocated throughout the usage of
the MTR in the entity constructor you'll
actually going to want to get rid of it
in the destructor because when they try
to get called that entity is gone you
can also call the destructor manually
not something that I see a lot of people
doing rightly so it's a bit weird if you
end up doing something like that the
only reason I can only think of doing
that is maybe if you've allocated using
new however when you delete it you
decide to use something like the free
function and then you also want to call
disrupt and manually make it I don't
know not really use that often but you
can do so by just calling e dot and see
you like this
as if it was any other function and that
will actually call the destructor if I
run this code which is innocent enough
you can see that it destroys the entity
twice seemingly we're not actually
releasing any resources here so it
doesn't crash it just prints this
message twice again not something I
would recommend or not something
often at all very very rarely asking
something like this so yeah destructors
sorted I'll see you guys next time good
bye
[Music]
[Music]